so the lore and elden ring is probably
one of the most complicated pieces of
storytelling i've ever tried to
understand one day i'll believe
something about the overall theme and
the objective of the game and the next
day i'll believe something completely
different based on some item description
i read off of some random flower
everything seems to connect while at the
same time discrediting everything else
i've spent the better part of this year
completely dedicated to learning and
understanding the world of elden ring
the moment i think i'm getting somewhere
is also the moment where i'm the most
confused it's like the game is designed
to be confusing and that's likely
because it was designed this way trying
to connect all of the dots when it comes
to elden ring lore is next to impossible
the best way for all of us to get
concrete evidence about what certain
things mean and connect to are the item
descriptions we can read on almost every
item in the game the only reason i say
concrete evidence is because it's plain
as day written down by the developers to
tell us what something is what it does
and what it means the rest of the
evidence we can gather from the game on
the lore isn't concrete in the slightest
dialogue is important in helping us
understand the intentions of other
characters we meet in the game but i
think it's important to note that even
npcs in the game can be wrong all the
characters have their own beliefs
perspectives and intentions the path one
character has journeyed on by the time
we meet and talk to them can be
drastically different from another
character that goes without saying but
it's not like we haven't been
manipulated into thinking one thing
based on what one character says and we
only learned later on that they were
just trying to swindle us and trick us
into just doing what they wanted so i
guess i shouldn't say that some
characters are wrong they're just as
confused as we are or they just believe
something different from us because
they've had a different experience in
the lands between than we have and that
just goes to show why there seems to be
such a divide in the community about the
lore of elden ring it's because we've
all had different experiences while
playing the game we're all going to have
different interpretations of what
something means what a character says
and what the environment is trying to
tell us it's all going to be different
for each person because we're all
different people with our own thoughts
beliefs aspirations doubts achievements
guidance and ultimately experiences and
that's the entire point of the game for
every player to have their own unique
experiences while playing the game and
sure there's guiding lights that tell us
where to go and weird characters telling
us what to do but how many of us
actually followed that line to a t and
listened to the first character we met
well apparently a lot of people did and
got tilted from it when it led us
straight to one of the hardest opening
bosses in all of video game history some
people will see this as annoying get
absolutely destroyed by market and quit
the game because they think it's too
hard they're too bad at the game and
they'll never be able to make it past
this obstacle then there's the other
type of person who won't follow that
light whatsoever and go explore every
area of the map find resources to
upgrade their weapons defeat every enemy
in a certain area thoroughly search
every dungeon in hidden area and they
won't even know margate exists until
about 40 hours into their first
playthrough this is just an example of
what i'm talking about we are all going
to have different experiences which is
why we're all going to have different
interpretations of the lore presented to
us in a completely non-linear way
because the game is completely open and
non-linear itself this non-linear
storytelling is not bad storytelling
it's completely by design it's meant to
match the experience of the game itself
and it's meant to be up to
interpretation of the player in their
own personal journey through the game
and then coming up with theories made by
everyone in the community when i make my
lore videos i receive a ton of comments
that just say no this is completely
wrong followed by paragraphs of
describing their own theory on that
subject and i think saying a theory in
elden ring could be straight up wrong is
like someone telling you your taste in
coffee is wrong just because i like a
little cream and sugar with my coffee
doesn't mean you drinking straight black
decaf is wrong i could think you're
weird for doing and thinking that and
tell you my own preference but you
aren't wrong for thinking that way i
think most people who think certain
theories can be wrong are likely players
who are mostly new to the souls games
they just don't understand that the
creators of these games purposely tell
stories like this i think zoli the witch
said it perfectly in a recent tweet
where she said something to always keep
in mind with lore discussion and from
software is that miyazaki isn't
interested in correct lore from
deliberately denies you information so
you can't really be certain what
miyazaki wants is for you to guess to
engage in media speculation and this is
exactly what i'm trying to say we aren't
meant to know the full story and we
aren't meant to know definitive
information on anything it's all up to
interpretation it's all up to your own
imagination from software does this
because they respect you as a player and
a person they believe that you're smart
enough to figure it out on your own and
like i said before this matches the
gameplay perfectly they don't tell you
how to do everything in the game from
the start because they want you to
figure it out and experience it on your
own they don't tell you what to do
because they want you to find your own
path they don't give you a quest log on
where to find the next npc location
because it makes it that much more
special when you find it on your own
does it make the experience harder
absolutely it does but if everything was
easy then it wouldn't be really worth
doing most games nowadays think the
players have absolutely no brain of
their own and they have to be handheld
through every single thing in the game
some of these games don't even let you
play the real game until you complete a
mundane tutorial where elden ring just
lets you walk right past it if that's
what you want to do from software gives
you the freedom to do anything that you
want to do and i appreciate their game
so much more because of this the best
way that i could put all of this is that
the story of elden ring is like a
painting when you look at a painting
you're going to have your own
interpretation of what that painting
means and what it's trying to show you
one person may think something totally
different from another about that
painting but it doesn't mean any
interpretation is wrong it's simply just
different is there anything wrong with
that of course there isn't it's a
beautiful thing to see others speculate
in different ways about something else
but for whatever reason some people just
don't like it when other people think
differently from them some of my best
friends and i think differently about
politics for example but it doesn't mean
that i don't still love them and love
being around them as a friend we just
think differently about certain things
it also doesn't mean that they're wrong
and i'm right or the other way around it
just means we think differently and
there's nothing wrong with that when it
comes to elden rings lore it's the same
way i may disagree about allure theory
but i'd never tell them that they're
just straight up wrong because i have no
idea if they're right or wrong because
none of us know it's just what they
think and what i think we can debate
speculate and make our own theories but
none of us are right or wrong we are
simply doing exactly what the game was
designed for us to do we are meant to
come up with our own interpretations
based on our own experiences it is so
much fun to watch videos on theories
that i may completely disagree with
because i love watching people speculate
and create theories that's a huge part
of the fun and it becomes not as fun
when people just argue and complain
about a theory that none of us really
know any definitive information on it
truly is amazing to see elden ring hit
the mainstream audience and it's brought
a ton of new players into the game and i
couldn't be happier about that and
obviously that's going to bring in some
players who just do not understand the
lore of all the souls games i just
wanted to talk about this topic as it's
something i feel pretty strongly about
so thank you guys for watching and thank
you all so much for 40 000 subscribers
it means the world to me so just know i
appreciate every single one of you the
next video will definitely be another
lore video on either malacath or an
updated theory on gideon off near so let
me know what you want to see next have a
great rest of your day and i'll see you
all in the next video take care
[Music]
you